amenazando la junta con represalias en
una extraña declaración tres de los
grupos étnicos armados insurgentes de
mianmar llamaron a la junta militar a
acabar con el baño de sangre si no se
detienen y continúan matando a la gente
cooperaremos con los manifestantes y
lucharemos fue una inusual muestra de
unidad por parte de estos grupos en un
país largo tiempo dividido por razones
étnicas y religiosas tras lograr la
independencia de gran bretaña en 1948
mianmar quedó fracturado entre un sinfín
de minorías culturales étnicas y
lingüísticas decenas de grupos rebeldes
tomaron las armas y comenzaron unas
luchas por el territorio la autonomía y
los recursos que pronto sobrepasó al
gobierno central en 1962 el ejército se
aprovechó de la situación para dar un
golpe militar y adueñarse
indefinidamente del poder dominada en
gran medida por la etnia bamar la junta
se presentó a sí misma como la única
fuerza capaz de unificar el país
con una estrategia de divide y vencerás
también impidieron que varios grupos
armados persiguieron intereses conjuntos
llegando a acuerdos individuales bajo
bastidores en 2015 diez de los
principales grupos armados de mianmar
firmaron un alto al fuego nacional y
acordaron deponer las armas a cambio de
mayor autonomía ahora un tercio del país
está directamente controlado por estas
facciones individuales que hasta este
punto habían quedado por largo tiempo
fuera de la política nacional pero el
frágil status quo fue sacudido por el
último golpe militar se produjo una
rápida condena por parte de varios
grupos rebeldes con tres de ellos
amenazado con una acción conjunta en
contra del ejército los expertos
advierten que el conflicto mianmar
podría sufrir una escalada e incluso
desembocar en una guerra civil